hey guys
welcome to simply learns youtube channel
this particular video is dedicated to
understand the top 10
dying programming languages in the year
2021
i have categorized this particular video
into two sections so the first section
will be dealing with the top five
programming languages
which are almost considered as obsolete
and no more fit for id development
followed by the first segment we have
our next segment which has the top five
programming languages
which are actually obsolete but still
have a major scope in the it development
now before we get started i would like
to tell you guys that we have daily
updates on multiple technologies
if you are a tech geek in continuous
hunt for the latest technological trends
then consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon
to stay updated for more videos from
simply learn
now let's get started
the top 10 dying programming languages
so we have categorized the programming
languages based on the community support
and the job opportunities offered
now the first segment dying programming
languages are
completely obsolete programming
languages at first
we have the assembly level programming
language it is said that the assembly
language helps programmer to write the
human readable code
that is almost similar to machine level
language
machine level language is difficult to
understand and read as it is just a
series of numbers
assembly language helps in providing
full control of what a computer is
performing
now let's look into the advantages that
the assembly language provided us
it was completely a hardware oriented
programming language and it was used for
critical jobs
it had very less number of instruction
lines and it was really memory efficient
now let's look into the drawbacks that
made it a completely obsolete
programming language
it takes a lot of time and effort to
write the code for the same
it is very complex to understand since
the syntax is very difficult to decode
and followed by that it had a very
complex control flow and the last point
the programming language was completely
platform specific which means
it did not offer the platform
independent nature of which the latest
object-oriented programming languages
like java offered
so followed by c plus programming
language we have the pascal programming
language
pascal was almost right with the
programming language c and a short time
after the basic programming language and
all these languages were influenced by
alcohol 60 that came out in the year
1960
and these languages were further
developed and given many
purposes with that now let's discuss the
advantages that pascal had
now it had a very good extensive error
checking capability
followed by that it had variety of data
structures in it
and it compiled in multiple platforms it
had object-oriented programming support
now let's also look into the drawbacks
it had which made it an obsolete
programming language
so the major issues of the pascal
programming languages were
the first one issues in control flow
when you write a complex program using
pascal programming language
then in sometimes in some specific
scenarios
the compiler will end up decoding the
code
in a different manner than what you
intended to do it actually
followed by that it also had some issues
in data structures like arrays
then it also had some issues in code
evaluation or expression evaluation
and lastly it had a lack of good library
support
so followed by pascal the next dying
programming language on the third number
is the haskell
so haskell is a general purpose
statically typed purely functional
programming language
with type interface and lazy evaluation
now let's look into the advantages that
haskell had it was a purely functional
programming language like c
then it has lazy evaluation so lazy
evaluation is something which makes the
programming language
lot efficient so no evaluation of up
code or an expression takes place
unless you provide the control flow to
that particular
statement so this kind of a feature
makes the programming language a lot
efficient
the processor won't have to waste its
energy
trying to be on standby without any
command
next followed by lazy evaluation we have
advanced code safety and finally
it offered a high level of safety to the
applications
now let's look into the drawbacks which
made it obsolete
so it had a complicated interface and it
was not suitable for critical
applications
it had a higher learning curve and it
was too tough to manage and learn in a
short term of time
and lastly it lacks widespread
implementations
now followed by haskell the next
programming language is the erlang
language the erlang is a general purpose
concurrent functional
programming language and a garbage
collected runtime system
so in this particular erlang language we
also had the garbage collector
now let's look into the advantages it
provided us
it was basically a functional
programming language it had a small
and simple syntaxes it also had superior
tools for packing and deploying of
applications
it can build robust applications so
these are the strong advantages provided
by olan language now let's look into the
drawbacks that made it an obsolete
programming language
so it had a tough time to set up and
deploy the applications
it had no proper library it was really
complex in debugging
and finally the hiring challenges so
most of the developers were not exposed
to erlang programming language
and companies had tough time finding
developers who had
good grip on airline programming
language
now followed by erlang we have the fifth
one which is the coffee script
coffeescript is a programming language
that compiles to javascript
it adds syntactic sugar inspired by ruby
python and haskell
in an effort to enhance javascript's
preferability
and readability specific additional
features
include a list of comprehension and
distracting assignment so some of the
major advantages that coffeescript
offered are
it was easy to understand the syntax of
this language is a very simple form of
javascript
so followed by that it had a novac
keyword unlike javascript there is no
need to use the
keyword before declaring a variable thus
it helps to avoid scope declaration
issues in a program
so followed by no wire keyword we have
the no symbols advantage
the symbols like semicolons parenthesis
and curly braces do not play
any major role in coffeescript instead
of these the white spaces
are used to differentiate the code
inside functions loops etc
and finally we have the less code
advantage in comparison to javascript
the lines of code reduces
into half benefit less code reduces
complexity in the program
so these were the major advantages of
coffeescript now let's look into the
drawbacks that made it an obsolete
programming language
so it was really difficult to set up the
environment for using coffeescript
it failed to integrate with high-end
libraries and it had terrible
error reports and it was difficult to
resolve exceptions in coffeescript
so these were the first five obsolete
and dying programming languages of our
list
now let's continue with the next half
which are considered as fading away
programming languages
but still have a little scope in the iit
industry
language is fading away so the first one
in here or the sixth one in the list is
the objective c
programming language so objective c is a
general purpose object oriented
programming language that adds
small talk style messaging to the c
programming language
now let's discuss the major advantages
that objective c
programming language had to offer so it
is basically mature and well tested
programming language
since it existed from a long period of
time for the apple developers
it is really mature and a well tested
programming language
followed by that it is a dynamic
programming language that interprets
developer thinking
it supports older versions till date and
it is a stable programming language
so now let's look into the drawbacks
that objective c had it had no exception
handling
it was low on security and it had
limited functionality and a complicated
syntax
so despite of its drawbacks i said that
these programming languages had a little
demand in the current iit industry
now let's look into the indeed.com for
analyzing the opportunities for the
developers
knowing objective-c programming language
so when you log into the indeed.com and
provide the objective-c
programming language and inside the city
some random city like
new york ny or chicago il
let's select new york so you can see
that we have 24
365 jobs available foreign
developer who knows objective c
programming language
this proves that this language might be
getting obsolete
and fading away but still it does have
demand in the mind
so followed by the sixth programming
language we have the seventh programming
language which is considered as a fading
kawaii programming language
that is the scala programming language
yes you heard me right it is a scala
programming language
so basically scala is a general purpose
programming language providing support
for both
object-oriented programming and
functional programming the language has
a strong static type system
scala is designed to be concise and many
of scala's designed decisions are aimed
to address
criticisms of java now let us look into
the advantages that scala provided
us so basically scala is both functional
and object oriented programming language
but mainly it is used as an
object-oriented programming language
followed by that it has a strong id
support since it is inherited from java
it does have a strong id support next it
is highly functional as discussed in the
first point
and finally it's better and developer
friendly
that means if you are a developer in
scala then you can switch
easily back to java as it is inherited
from java
so you can work on both java as well
scale it's like having a two-sided sword
now let us look into the disadvantages
which make it an obsolete programming
language
it is said that the tools in scala are
highly immature and it is complex and
hard to learn
as well as it has got some limited
documentation and limited developer
support
since it runs on jvm it has no true tail
recursive optimization as walk around
you can use the add the rate trail
recording annotation for practical
benefits
scalar has limited developer pool but
while it is easier to find java
developers in numbers
not every java developer knows what it
takes to be a scalar developer
in an efficient way so these are some of
the major drawbacks that make scala
as an obsolete or fading away
programming language
followed by this let's look into the
next one
the cobol programming language yes you
heard it right
cobol is still in demand yet it is
fading away so cobol is a compiled
english like computer programming
language designed for business use
it has imperative procedural and since
2002
object oriented cobol is primarily used
in business finance and administrative
systems for companies and governments
now let's look into the advantages that
global programming language had to offer
you can use cobol programming language
as a self-documenting programming
language
kobo language can handle massive data
processing it is one of the primarily
used high level programming languages
it is fully compatible with its past
versions and cobol programming language
can handle bugs
in a most effective manner and
followed by the advantages now let's
look into the drawbacks which made it
go fade away or an obsolete programming
language
so it had a wordy syntax it is really
complicated to format the code
it had no scientific applications other
than the business applications
and lastly it is very slow in
compilation
despite of these drawbacks we said that
it had some
decent demand in the iit industry now
let's go back to the indeed.com and
check for the
openings for cobol so when we log into
indeed.com and search for cobol job
opportunities in the united states of
america
then we can see 815 jobs available
which is like a little less than 1 000
jobs which is also a decent number
now in our list the next fading away
programming language followed by cobol
is the pearl programming language so
pearl also known as the practical
extraction and reporting language is a
high level language
that is used for general purpose
programming it is a fundamental
portability
of unix boxes along with many other
systems high portability of the scripts
is one of the best features
that can be achieved if system specific
functions can be avoided
now let's look into the advantages that
pearl had to offer us
so perl includes amazing program
dialects good file handling properties
file is an open source programming
language and finally it is a
multi-purpose programming language
yet it had some drawbacks now let's look
into them
so perl was considered as it has slow
scripts and it was having difficult
syntax
it was really hard to read and finally
it had poor argument handling
yet we also said that it had some decent
demand in the industry
now let's get back to indeed.com and
search for
perl
so when you see pearl in indie.com in
united states of america
we have 11 287 jobs
still awakened for world developers so
it is still in high demand in the united
states of america
yet it is considered as a fading away
programming language
so followed by pearl the top 10th
programming language which is considered
as an obsolete or fading away
programming language is the
visual basic.net programming language
so visual basic.net or vb.net is a
computer programming language developed
by microsoft
it was released in the year 2002 to
replace the visual basic
6. vb.net is an object-oriented
programming language
this means that it supports the features
of object-oriented programming which
includes encapsulation polymorphism
abstraction
and inheritance now let us look into the
advantages that vb.net had to offer
so it was really simple and easy to
understand programming language
it uses a graphical user interface and
it is completely appealing
it offers component integration and
finally it had automatic code formatting
also it had some drawbacks now let's
look into the drawbacks which
vb.net had so it had issues with code
transfer that it is
not platform independent followed by
that it had a problem with pointers
it was inefficient in processing and
finally there was
a major problem that is job insecurity
now let's look for the demand it has
currently in the it industry
let's get back to indeed.com so when we
logged into indeed.com and search for
vb.net developers in the united states
of america
then we found that there are 1756
job openings currently awakened which is
a little less than 2 000 so it's a
decent number
now it proves that vb.net still has some
demand in the iit industry so with that
we have come to an end of this
particular video i hope this session was
useful
if you have any queries regarding this
session then please feel free to write
us down in the comment section below
and we will have your queries answered
from our experts as early as possible
this is ravi signing off until next time
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here